encore vient d'être mis en puissance les
quatre réacteurs sont à fond j'ai un
côté de moi monsieur rebufer qui est
spécialiste du centre d'essais en vol de
brétigny et qui est spécialement belle
épine de concorde
je suis au but et je prends plus de 625
à la mise en prison c'est complètement
fou rire actuellement encore dhabi
près de six ans vous voyez la fumée qui
dégage des réacteurs je pense que vous
les cédez pas à intervenir dans très peu
de temps
nous allons maintenant donc assister à
ce premier vol
qui est un pendule
depuis deux ans
à 2002
le jour
le concorde est prévu et maintenant
enfin le premier
ce premier vol que
un quart de tour de la piste et que vous
tous allés voir maintenant en direct
le voilà
les albums là
ça y est
water de moi j'entends des cris de joie
des applaudissements
parvient
john kerry
et maintenant la vitesse de 350 km qui
est celle de son décollage pas encore de
grave
maintenant il va grimper à environ 400
mètres à la minute
douze longs pieds et gagner l'attitude
de 3500 à 4000 m
cette première pressée est extrêmement
grave
ça y est d'avion d'accompagnement a
réussi à raccorder en image chez nous
avons concorde en vol je vous rappelle
que pour ce premier vol concorde doit
voler train sortie n'est baissé il n'est
pas question qu andré turcat remonte le
train d'atterrissage ne remonte le nez
et bien le général calme elle vient de
nous aider les indications concernant
cette dernière phase de vol vous voyez
la magnifique image de concorde s'est
déclenché sur fond de sol et autour de
moi j'en fais déjà le voilà le voilà je
pense que nous allons le voir dans l'axé
de la piste d'ici peu effectivement je
l'aperçois sur la droite tourner les
deux hélicoptères de surveillance et
voici la dernière phase que va faire
andré turcat concorde on est en finale
il semble qu'il va se poser réellement
voilà nous le voyons apparaître dans
l'axé de la piste
semble-t-il
je crois qu'il va faire un atterrissage
simulait oui effectivement il semble un
peu haut pour un atterrissage réel
monsieur revue fait je ne sais pas
encore c'est andré turcat qui va
apprécier
et l'affairé il battait
magnifique atterrissage l'ouverture du
parachute freins autour de nous des
applaudissements vraiment depuis si
longtemps que nous attendions ce premier
vol vraiment autour de nous tout le
monde est heureux
epages suite page immédiatement monsieur
rébus fait pour vous pour vous qui êtes
un spécialiste des desserts aux valses
alouettes une joie j'ai suppose une très
grande joie oui mais enfin c'est une
joie je pense pour tous pour toute
l'équipe pour tout ce qu'ils ont réalisé